all right guys how you doing greg and
john here i don't think this is
super bowl related but the international
japanese trailer for godzilla vs kong
came out
so i was like well there's gotta be more
interrupt our american game for some
japanese trailer today
let's do this
subscribe to heavy spoilers we haven't
done so already by the way
i already got chills on my nips
every time all right
yeah is that who that is
you know a lot of people like this rap
song but i like this song on the trailer
i personally do
oh okay
[Music]
okay yeah
godzilla got a hit
oh that was a cool damn there's some
there's some more godzilla footage in
this one
all this yeah
subscribe to this guy if you haven't
done so right he's a great dude all
right so it's essentially kind of like
the same trailer in a lot of ways but
weirdly those new placements of
different
footage and also the rearranging of some
of the footage here because
it's a lot of the same clips but a lot
of the footage has been rearranged
with the new footage it actually makes
the playing field between the two of
them
feel more even yeah whereas in the other
trailer it seemed to really be like
godzilla's bad we're rooting for kong
and in this
trailer it made them both feel kind of
equal and they even emphasized them more
with that millie bobby brown shot of
like
no there's something doing this to
godzilla it's not him
it's they can't just be him that's my
milly bobby brown impression what's up
dudes
i'm on stranger things
becoming more adult that's how you do it
you just become a chainsmoker
and then also of course the shot to like
you get a shot at godzilla actually
landing a hit
yeah which i was grateful for and the
shot two was blasting the city that's in
the other trailer but this is a much
closer shot yeah yeah and it clicked
with me part way through i was like oh
it's the international japanese trailer
of course what they've done is they've
leveled it out with more godzilla
yeah exactly the natural leveling of the
playing field happens through that it's
like even just i think in the
literal fact that they both trade blows
on the ship
too yeah with the show the shot
everyone's freaking out about where kong
punches him and then you get a shot
later where
godzilla hits him yeah yeah so all right
guys
this is badass i love that man all right
honestly i could watch like
if there's like a second in new footage
i'm excited for it looks so good because
of all those two second clips
genius wp knew what they were doing man
all right guys
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button check out the other
gvk videos we've done before keep
looking for more coming out today
[Music]